[Musique]
je viens d'accéder sans aucune
difficulté à X vidéo un des plus gros
sites pornographiques sans qu'il n'est
vraiment vérifié mon âge c'est
précisément ce que reproche l'arcom
l'Autorité de régulation de
l'audiovisuel à 5 sites pornographiques
ne pas empêcher l'accès des mineurs
alors plateforme alors que la loi les
oublie alors pourquoi ces sites ne se
soumettent-ils pas à la législation elle
aurait-elle suffisamment contraignante
et les moments de réponse dans factures
en France le code pénal interdit
formellement d'exposer des mineurs à des
contenus pornographiques la loi du 30
juillet 2020 sur les violences
conjugales stipule qu'aucun site à
caractère pornographique ne peut
s'affranchir de sa responsabilité et
doit empêcher l'accès des mineurs à ses
comptes dans les faits il suffit
simplement de tester de son âge pour
ouvrir un site à caractère
pornographique donc au mieux on va
demander à l'internaute de mettre sa
date de naissance au pire c'est juste
une case à cocher qui dit je certifie
d'avoir plus de 18 ans et c'est tout
d'un point de vue pénal ces sites risque
d'être bloqué mais dans les faits la
procédure judiciaire est toujours en
cours et les sites toujours accessibles
le fond du problème c'est que on demande
au site de vérifier l'âge des mineurs
mais sans dire que la méthode à
appliquer et en fait c'est ça le nom du
problème car s'il existe des moyens de
vérifier l'identité des utilisateurs ces
méthodes se heurtent ou principe de
protection des données personnelles la
CNIL Commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés le signal
dans un avis rendu le 3 juin 2021 un
système de notifications de l'identité
des utilisateurs serait tout simplement
illégal elle rappelle que l'exigence de
mise en place d'un dispositif de
vérification de la majorité d'âge à des
fins légitimes de préservation des
mineurs ne saurait justifier une
obligation général identification avec
une pièce d'identité par exemple
une autre solution c'est d'utiliser donc
la reconnaissance faciale donc cette
sert que il va y avoir un logiciel qui
va scanner votre visage et qui va
estimer si oui ou non vous avez plus de
18 ans cette solution aussi est
imparfaite elle n'est pas forcément très
précise pour estimer l'âge et mettant
danger la vie privée des utilisateurs et
donc là on peut imaginer toutes sortes
d'extorsions de fonds toutes sortes de
menaces toutes sortes de on va prendre à
votre insu des captures d'écran des
vidéos de votre domicile qui peuvent
être servis contre vous une autre
méthode envisagée pourrait être
l'utilisation d'une carte bancaire avec
une transaction nulle part du principe
que si vous avez une carte bancaire
c'est que a priori vous êtes majeur elle
n'est pas non plus en train suffisante
et est accessible des saisons et un
mineur peut tout à fait subtiliser celle
d'un avion l'interface d'identification
France Connect plateforme étatique a
aussi été suggéré pour contrôler l'âge
des utilisateurs mais contrôler l'accès
à ces sites ne relève pas du rôle de
l'État qui ne peut s'immiscer ainsi dans
la vie privée de ses utilisateurs le
rapport de la CNIL pointe en plus un
risque d'usurpation intensité liée à la
dévulation et au possible détournement
de ces données personnelles la CNIL
suggère dans son rapport de passer par
un tiers de confiance qui ne soit pas
l'état cette méthode devrait intégrée un
mécanisme de double anonymat empêchant
d'une part le tir de confiance
d'identifier le site ou l'application à
l'origine d'une demande de vérification
et d'autre part faisant obstacle à la
transmission des données identifiantes
ce système a été mis en place
conjointement par la CNIL le pôle
d'expertise de régulation numérique le
pérenne et des chercheurs de
Polytechnique Olivier bladi chercheur en
informatique rattaché à Polytechnique à
travailler à mettre en place cette
méthode il s'est basé sur les différents
niveaux d'âge existant dans la loi
française plus de 13 ans plus de 15 ans
et plus de 18 ans ou plus de 18 ans
c'est tout ce qui est ici pour adultes
devant d’alcool si devant un site de
jeux en ligne et plus 13 et + 15 en fait
c'est pour les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'en théorie un mineur n'a pas le droit
de s'inscrire sur un réseau social si la
moins de 13 ans et entre 13 et 15 ans
pour s'inscrire il va avoir le
consentement de ses parents ainsi la
maison était certificatrices sans
transmettre son identité va pouvoir
garantir que l'utilisateur à l'âge
nécessaire pour accéder au site ce qui
va se passer concrètement c'est quand
une personne va essayer d'accéder à un
de ces sites le site va mettre une
espèce de warning une boîte où il va
dire j'ai besoin de faire un contrôle et
va envoyer ce qu'on appelle un token
jeton à l'utilisateur l'utilisateur va
recevoir ce jeton qui est juste un
nombre aléatoire très grand et à
transmettre ce jeton à l'autorité
certificatrice donc il a confiance et
l'autorité va répondre en regardant ce
jeton va répondre la personne a plus de
13 ans plus de 15 ans les moins de 18
par exemple donc l'utilisateur va
recevoir cette réponse et va rentrer se
mettre que le goût pertinent de la
réponse donc c'est à dire si c'est un
site qui essaye de tester si la plus de
15 ans va juste transmettre
voilà cette personne a plus de 15 ans
grâce à ce mécanisme l'autorité
certificatrices ne s'est pas pour
qu'elle cite elle est en train de
répondre et le site qui reçoit la
réponse ne peut pas connaître l'identité
de l'utilisateur
mais si ce système est possible il doit
être encore validé par le législateur et
l'État doit négocier avec les sites qui
ne trouvent aucun intérêt à installer ce
système sachant qu'il restera toujours
un moyen de contourner ce mécanisme
n'oublions pas qu'il reste toujours une
solution pour contourner ses blocages
qui est tout simplement d'utiliser un
VPN donc ce sont des logiciels qui font
croire que vous êtes connecté depuis un
autre pays et dans ces cas-là le site
qui n'est plus soumis à la loi française
n'est plus dans l'obligation de
contrôler la journée ça c'est ce
problème là on ne peut rien faire en
tout cas ce n'est dans nos mains on n'a
pas de solution technique qui permet de
dire remédier aujourd'hui la meilleure
manière d'empêcher l'accéder des sites
pornographiques aux mineurs restent le
contrôle parental largement plébiscité
par les associations de protection des
mineurs mais il revient aux parents de
l'installer et dans les fait les sites
qu'on tourne toujours l'obligation
légale
[Musique]